this is the simplest formula for the
projection right for the vector
projection but there's there's more than
one way to write this formula and so in
fact maybe we should just revise right
um you know we've also seen actually I
need a bit more space so I'm going to
move this down we've also seen this
before with the dot product itself the
dot product itself has more than one way
to be calculated
um we proved how these two formulas are
equal to each other but it really
depends on what information you have
access to right so the definition we've
already just used today
what you need is the magnitudes of the
two vectors and the angle in between
right what was the other definition
again
or formula I should say just the
multiplication of the
um X wines and coordinates together yeah
absolutely so we take the product of the
components so here's the first product
the X's here's the Y product and then
here's the Z product right
now of course what you can do is if you
if you have all the components you can
work out the magnitude and then you can
also work out the angle but if you just
have the components you just want to go
straight to the dot product would use
the second one right now in exactly the
same way there are multiple formulas for
the projection it just depends like you
move between them depending on what
information you've got right so just as
this is true uh where am I going to
write this so to
for the projection
now can I just ask you guys do you know
how many forms there are that we sort of
commonly use I just show you there's one
but there's more than one does anyone
how many of you encountered I guess
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
just two okay so I'm what I'm going to
do is I'm going to give you a third one
okay and um they are all actually pretty
similar to each other as you'll see but
it just depends on on what information
you've got okay so I'm going to draw
like a big fat curly brace here so the
first one is the one we already just saw
right so first you get the scale apart
the length of the Shadow like so and
then you multiply by the direction of
the Shadows so that's the direction of
the base Vector okay so I would call
this one this one here is the most
concise version
so if you want to memorize something
this is the least to memorize okay
now another way you can say this is you
can actually remember the the dot
product is just magnitude of one vector
magnitude of the other and then you
multiply by the angle in between but
just have a look for a second right
here's one vector but this Vector here B
hat it's a it's a unit Vector so what's
the magnitude of this vector by
definition
it's just it's just one right so when
you go and calculate the dot product
that that magnitude just sort of cancels
out right so therefore what we can say
is
um it's the magnitude of the first
Vector the magnitude of the second one
which is just one and then it's the
angle in between so this is another way
of saying that scalar projection this is
the length of the Shadow and then just
like before we have to multiply by the
direction so that we we're headed in the
right way okay so when would you use
this version well if in the question
either you're given the angle or you
were asked the angle like you had to
work it out in an earlier part if um if
the if the angle is known then you would
just use this one
right because it just cuts out some of
the work for you okay
all right now the third and final uh
form of this formula remember I
highlighted how strange it was that this
concise formula has b-hat and B hat in
it again you're like what's this
obsession with B hats in the same
formula okay well this last version of
the formula is the weirdest one
um and I'm going to show it to you um as
a sort of explanation for why it's weird
but actually it ends up being very very
useful maybe this is the one you've seen
before okay
um all right how do I explain this um
see how you got this B hat here and this
B hat here if I gave you some Vector B
what would you do to it to work out the
unit Vector that corresponds to it we
actually did it earlier what do you do
yeah you divide by the magnitude okay
now here you can see you've actually got
b-hat happening twice so if you wanted
um to not have the b-hats there you
would have to have the original vector
and divide by its magnitude but you do
it twice right you do it twice so
instead of working out like dividing
through by the square root that's how
you work out Manchester right yeah you
you said it when you square that
magnitude which you know is going to be
a square root because of Pythagoras when
you square that all you just get is the
the components right so it'd just be
um x b squared and then y b squared and
then z b squared right so it's just all
the the Pythagorean the three other
parts Civic Pythagorean quadruple okay
now
funniest and most ridiculous part right
a way you can work this out
is by taking that Vector B and then
doing the dot product to itself you've
actually seen this before it was in the
previous exercise right so what I can do
is are you ready I can say don't do a
dot b hat just do the original Vector
right and then don't multiply that by B
hat just multiply that by the original
Vector but then in order to get your
magnitudes right you have to divide by
that the magnitudes twice right so the
way you can do that is by dividing by B
and it's dot product to gate itself
um that is one of the most ridiculous
formulas I've ever seen because you're
like wow someone really likes b a lot
but I hope you can kind of see why it is
what it is because what you're doing is
this part here gives you one of the B
hats and then this part here gives you
the other B hat you're not dividing B by
B
um when you do this thing down the
bottom you you just get that that scalar
right so you're dividing by them
magnitude effectively
so even though it's a bit strange right
what this actually does is it is
um it's automating the process of
working out what b-hat is you I'm going
to give you an example in a second this
automates the calculation
of the unit vector
if you want to think about it this way
do you guys remember learning the
quadratic formula the first time
so it's we've actually rehearsed it just
recently it's um this right
now I don't know how many of you realize
that all the quadratic formula is doing
is it's taking a normal quadratic like
so
and then what it's doing is it's
completing the square but the formula
takes out your need to remember the
steps of completing the square it's all
just built into the algebra of the
quadratic formula and that's exactly
what this version of the the projection
formula does it takes out you having to
remember oh I need to work out the um uh
the unit Vector okay
all right so three forms
um do you guys have any questions I can
hear a lot of talking there but I don't
know if it's a classroom outside or
something like that
okay perfect timing all right great
um
yeah this is very funny by the way just
a very short note I know this sounds
silly but every time I look at this last
formula here with all the bees in it
um I actually remember a music teacher I
had in year seven and he was he was
saying the notes of a of a piece so that
we could play it on piano and the note
that he the the music he was playing it
had um like five notes of b in a row and
he literally just said this so I
actually hear his voice singing that
song when I look at this formula so
that's completely irrelevant but anyway
let's have a look at one example shall
we now the computation of this is I hope
going to be pretty straightforward but
the first question is you have three
different ways to work out a projection
of one vector onto another they're the
three formulas here and I want you to
tell me which of these three formulas is
probably the most useful
now there's one formula that hopefully
we can all eliminate fairly quickly as
an option which one is not that relevant
[Music]
it's the uh yeah it's the it's I think I
heard it sorry I can hear a lot of yeah
thank you Mrs Isles um it's the one in
the middle right because we don't have
an angle given to us and we're not asked
to work out the angle so I'm not going
to work out the angle if I don't have to
right so what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to not worry about I'll put a
an X against this middle one so then
it's a case of the the other two now
remember we said that this last version
oh sorry the first version requires you
to work out what b-hat is let me just
very quickly there's there's B there on
the right hand side right let's just uh
think about what would be required if I
were to work out B hat right well
think about this with me it's going to
be B and I'm going to have to divide by
its magnitude now what is this magnitude
well it's going to be I have to take the
X and the Y and the Z components and I
Square them right
like so
now do you guys remember
um and earlier in an earlier lesson I
gave you guys a question and it was very
obvious that I had planned it so that
the numbers would be kind of nice when
you took a square root it all ended up
as integers right when you have a look
at this you're like oh gross that square
root of three it's it's not going to go
anywhere right
um and so what you're going to get as
b-hat is actually going to be
um b-hat will be equal to here's the
original Vector up the top so it's going
to be all right you ready minus one on
root three then one on root three and
then one on root three again
that's the unit Vector that's really
gross right and so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to you can actually look
very quickly like if you're wondering
should I which one should I use right in
this case you can see the unit Vector is
not nice and neat so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to go for this third
version of the formula
and you're going to see actually it's
going to be um it's going to be really
nice to work with so let's just have a
go you guys can help me out
the projection of a onto B
uh I'm going to show you the way that I
I write this so um I've got the two uh
uh rather not the two I've got the
fraction in in the front there and then
I'm going to have that Vector B like so
so I'm just going to write the vector B
right away because there's no uh
calculation or computation required
there and now I'm going to think about
the two dot products okay so um I've got
to do a onto B first um dot product of a
to B so you can see here the numbers
right
here's the number here there's a number
there so can you guys tell me multiply
your x's and then your y's and then your
z's what am I going to get uh just tell
me the products
negative four
positive two and then
minus three minus three okay you really
gotta watch out a few signs there right
it's like maximum number of sides to be
confusing okay very good that's that
we've already actually sort of thought
about the dot product of B onto itself
because we sort of were thinking about
it over here this is just going to be
one plus one plus one like so okay
so then when you have a look at this
you're like oh okay this is just going
to be on the numerator that's uh
negative five on the denominator it's
um a three and then actually I don't
need to I mean I could multiply this in
but I don't need to right this scale of
multiple that's it that that's the whole
that's the whole question that is number
one
um
uh this part here
is the um
uh the the magnitude of it and then you
know its direction over here from the
right hand side okay now just have a
think right if you had used this formula
basically what's going to happen is all
those root threes are going to cancel
with another root 3 is going to appear
so it's a bit of a mess to end up with
all those thirds and then get rid of
those thirds um so there's no real
reason to to go using that formula okay
okay uh any questions how are you doing
so far
I've already asked you to find the
inspector yeah that's right if the unit
Vector came up somewhere
um maybe like you said in an earlier
part of the question or alternatively
um sometimes the unit Vector is actually
easy to calculate like they've handed
you a vector where the unit Vector is
supposed to be simple to calculate
um and you can see what I did was over
here on the right hand side what I
checked was is it easy to calculate uh
gross no thanks right I would normally I
would not write this I would kind of do
this a little bit mentally if you have a
look and you think about these numbers
in here
um if I if I had given you say for
example negative one four four
um because I've been doing a lot of
these questions I recognize that as
three quarters of a Pythagorean
quadruple so I'll be like oh it'll work
right um it'll be convenient I'll get
integers out and so I'll I'll run with
it um but in this case I could mentally
see already that I don't want to do it
it's going to introduce certs and I'm
probably going to get rid of them
um but here's the here's the nice thing
if you choose the wrong one quote
unquote the wrong one you will still
arrive at the same answer it's just a
little more work that's all okay